[Musica]
buon pomeriggio
comincio con una domanda vi siete mai
chiesti perché alcune tecnologie che
utilizziamo sono belle emozionanti ci
divertono
ci piace utilizzarle ed altre invece
sono frustranti sono fredde immagino che
sarà capitato a tutti voi di dover
studiare un intero manuale per per
esempio decidere la temperatura da un
termostato di casa il termostato forse
una delle cose più frustranti che ci
sono
voglio caldo e non riesco a farlo eppure
eppure questo ci succede ci succede ogni
giorno all'ora per provare a capire
insieme che cosa c'è di bello
nell'interazione con le tecnologie vi
racconto una una piccola storia allora
immaginate di essere in un in un negozio
volete comprare dei dei biscotti la
persona che vi sta servendo prende i
biscotti per il boot e ai piedi e i
biscotti si rompono e voi dovete
piegarvi per raccoglierli sarebbe
possibile accettare un servizio di
questo genere
nessuno di noi accetterebbe potrebbe
accettare di essere trattato in questo
modo in un negozio
eppure questo è come è quello che ci
succede utilizzando alcune tecnologie
pensate ai distributori automatici le
macchinette ne stavamo parlando poco fa
prendendo un caffè
i distributori automatici di bibite o di
merendine vogliamo qualcosa dobbiamo
inserire
inserire le monete dobbiamo leggere un
codice digitare un codice vedere se
corrisponde veramente a quello che
abbiamo spingere un bottone la merendina
cade dall'alto in un cassetto buio
dobbiamo chinarci ficcare la mano dentro
spesso c'è un effetto tagliola spesso
abbiamo delle cose in mano e quindi è
difficile pensate anche a persone che
hanno problemi hanno delle disabilità
hanno delle difficoltà spesso nei posti
pubblici questi contenitori sono anche
sporchi e dobbiamo metterci la mano
dentro la tecnologia non ci tratta con
rispetto vogliamo essere rispettati nel
nostro modo di interagire con le
macchine e questa panda è stata posta
degli studenti del corso di master e in
industrial design all indomani
university of technology e hanno provato
a immaginare un altro tipo di
distributore automatico
[Musica]
che cosa c'è di bello in questa
interazione di bello cioè che i prodotti
cercano di sedurci si girano si voltano
si mostrano quando passiamo di bello c'è
che usiamo un linguaggio naturale usiamo
un gesto diciamo io voglio quello non
devo leggere un codice non devo inserire
un numero non devo fare nulla di tutto
questo perché questo è il modo in cui ci
relazioniamo nella vita di tutti i
giorni di bello cioè l'estetica
dell'interazione la macchina si apre in
un modo molto bello e si offre offre il
prodotto alla alla persona ecco questo è
il bello che c'è nell'interazione e
guardate che ogni giorno utilizzano
tecnologie che ci promettono
un'interazione molto engaging
un'interazione che ci coinvolge possiamo
spostare oggetti cliccare possiamo
muovere delle icone
ma che cosa veramente tocchiamo quando
tocchiamo un touch screen
tocchiamo degli oggetti che non hanno
qualità non sentiamo l'attrito non
sentiamo la materia di cui sono composti
non hanno una texture quante volte
vediamo persone sul cellulare che dicono
dai sbrigati perché magari vogliono fare
una foto è l'oggetto si sta muovendo la
macchina non risponde non riconosce alla
nostra espressività
eppure noi siamo molto espressivi nella
vita di tutti i giorni non non
funzioniamo con un'interazione di tipo
on off
non aspettiamo che qualcuno ci chiede
una cosa per rispondere e le tecnologie
oggi non funzionano così
e allora come funziona l'interazione
nella vita di tutti i giorni ci sono due
aspetti
t che sono importanti nell'interazione
con gli oggetti
uno è la continuità nell'interazione noi
interagiamo continuamente io vi sto
guardando è adatto fare al modo in cui
voi vi state guardando ed è continua uno
scambio continuo e l'altro punto
importante è che l'interazione è
espressiva
guardate questa rancia il modo in cui io
riesco a spremerla dipende dalla
grandezza della mia mano dalla forza che
esercito dal da ciò che voglio avere
quindi esprimo un intenzione di ottenere
un certo feedback dalla macchina e alla
ci siamo chiesti ma è possibile
strizzarla un'interfaccia e
apparentemente sì abbiamo occupato un
progetto molto interessante questa è una
cover per tablet che abbiamo modellato
in 3d abbiamo stampato in 3d in gomma
morbida come vedete abbiamo inserito
dell'elettronica dei sensori di
pressione degli attuatori sono dei
piccoli motori che danno una
restituzione un feedback tattile quando
si strizza e abbiamo sviluppato una
piccola applicazione per fare lo zoom
quando facciamo delle fotografie
[Musica]
bene questa questo tipo di interazione
volevamo ovviamente provarla e l'abbiamo
comparata con le altre modalità che sono
native dei tablet
quella che vedete sulla sinistra e lo
slide quando dobbiamo muovere quella
rotellina per fare lo zoom ma anche con
il pinch e l'abbiamo provata l'abbiamo
provata in piazza del campo abbiamo
coinvolto in questo studio 70 persone
prese a caso tra chiunque passasse
piazza del campo abbiamo dato la cover
abbiamo chiesto di fare una foto
dell'orologio della torre del mangia e
abbiamo chiesto loro di compilare un
questionario e abbiamo visto che al di
là di un piccolo iniziale così
incertezza per provare per provare
questo sistema
in realtà le persone apprezzavano
moltissimo le qualità e doni che di
questo di questo prodotto e quindi si
divertivano lo sentivano lo provavano
provavano a fare delle foto diverse da
come le fanno normalmente questo è un
sistema che lavora diciamo sul come
diceva domenico prattichizzo prima
lavoriamo sulle mani e sul modo di
interagire con le mani e con le dita ma
questo concetto di espressività lo
possiamo estendere a tutto il corpo
sempre nel mio laboratorio abbiamo
sviluppato una serie di strumenti
musicali in cartone lavoriamo moltissimo
con materiale riciclato perché vogliamo
sviluppare prototipi prima di andare poi
a fare uno sviluppo più importante
proprio per rendere espressivo il corpo
e poter suonare questo è
un
sono 220 quest'annata insomma
[Musica]
ecco e per serendipity come qualcuno
diceva questa mattina
l'abbiamo provata con dei bambini che si
sono divertiti da morire a suonare con
questi strumenti e l'abbiamo provata per
caso con dei bambini con dislessia e li
abbiamo fatti re pare le abbiamo chiesto
loro di scrivere un piccola strofa di
una canzone
abbiamo chiesto loro dire pare e di
suonare con questi strumenti che si
indossano e abbiamo visto che facevano
molti meno errori sia nella lettura che
nella produzione del dl parlato del
cantato in questo caso il valore della
prototipazione dell'espressione del
corpo della tangibilità di certe
tecnologie è davvero interessante
l'ultimo caso che voglio farvi vedere ed
è un po un caso storico per il mio
laboratorio è un lavoro abbiamo una
collaborazione da ormai 15 anni con
l'università di tsukuba in giappone e
abbiamo importato dall'italia questo
robot si chiama paro è un cucciolo di
foca è una foca robotica che utilizziamo
con persone con vari tipi di disabilità
la disabilità motoria cognitiva ma più
recentemente abbiamo fatto molti studi
con anziani con demenza le signore che
vedete in questo in questo video appunto
sono persone che hanno livelli diversi
di demenza abbiamo lavorato anche con
persone con alzheimer in frase
aggressiva il
la foca lavora su un concetto molto
interessante che quello del prendersi
cura del cocco l'ars i del quando si
abbraccia fa le fusa sbatte gli occhi la
possiamo addestrare a un algoritmo di
apprendimento per cui impara a
riconoscere a sentire la voce a voltarsi
ad alcuni richiami
ecco è chiaramente ispirata come potete
immaginare la pet therapy
ma la cosa importante qui è che con le
tecnologie possiamo stabilire anche un
legame di tipo emotivo un coinvolgimento
di tipo emotivo vedere queste signore
che normalmente sono isolate non fanno
molto durante il giorno non parlano
vederle sorridere scambiarsi toccarsi di
citare memorie del passato
loro sanno esattamente che hanno tra le
mani una macchina perché noi glielo
diciamo subito appena cominciamo a
lavorare con loro ma non gliene importa
assolutamente nulla il legame affettivo
la presa in carico la cura è
fondamentale ecco questo questa diciamo
questo breve excursus di progetti e per
dire che possiamo progettare pensando
all'essere umano
a metterlo al centro del nostro della
nostra attività di progettazione
pensarci a persone con un corpo
un'espressività con un'intenzionalità e
quindi produrre tecnologie che vanno al
di là dell'aspetto funzionale del dl
risolvere un problema ma lavorare anche
facendo leva su altre caratteristiche
dell'essere umano
concludo dicendo che tutti questi lavori
sono possibili grazie a un gruppo di
ricercatori con cui ho la fortuna di
lavorare del
nel laboratorio di robotica e tecnologie
per l'apprendimento dell'università di
siena e del fab lab del santa chiara
dove siamo ospitati a un gruppo di
ragazzi giovani motivati preparati molto
collaborativi che io ringrazio e
ringrazio voi per la vostra attenzione
[Musica]